[Music]  don't expect to see Queen B at the 2018  Met Gala et has exclusively learned that  Beyonce will not attend the annual  soiree pulling out at the last minute to  go on a surprise vacation with her hubby  jay-z a source tells ET quote jay-z  surprised her with a trip because he  felt she needed to relax before her tour  the couple is set to kick off on the run  too at this June our source adds that  Beyonce was planning on attending Vogue  and the Mets big night and even had a  custom gown in the works by Dundas the  designer behind the brand Peter Dundas  had been working for weeks on the custom  creation he was the creative mind behind  her 2017 a Grammys performance look you  trying to leave it this marks the second  year in a row that B has opted out of  the gala  - last year she was still very pregnant  with twins Rumi and sir  [Music]  [Applause]